Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on, guys.
Is Rob. And in this video, we are going to explain the character of red Hawk.
Now, the reason why we're doing this is one because I miss doing character
explanations and two,
because I believe it's Jacob H is one of our higher tier patrons.
And if you're a high enough tier on Patrion,
you can actually request to have a character explanation video made or a beyond
Omega level video made. And if you're even higher, you can actually get both.
So Jacob requested that we do a video on red hook explained,
and that's what we're going to do. So red Hawk, or I guess,
general Thunderbolt Ross first appeared in Marvel comics with the incredible
Hulk number one in may of 1962,
of course he was created like most people back then by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby.
But here's the funny thing, the origins of Thunderbolt Ross,
like a lot of characters in Marvel are just kind of scattered all over the place
specifically in the incredible hope. Number one, uh,
tales to astonish number 61 and, uh,
the incredible Hulk number 291.
Now another thing that kind of goes on here is something called control and
control was, uh, was something that showed up in conspiracy. Number one,
which was this interesting line of comics that Marvel did back in 1998,
that was made, that was done by a Dan Abnett. But for this particular purpose,
we're going to focus on, on those original three issues that we had mentioned,
right? So the idea of Thunderbolt Ross,
in terms of his creation of the hands of Stanley and judge Herbie,
was that much like a lot of the comics back then Stanley did recognize the idea
that the incredible Hulk was kind of like this giant green rage monster,
but more so than that,
Stan Lee was all about the idea of focusing on the human element of characters
in the sense that who are they beyond,
like whatever fantastic powers they happen to hat. And so where,
where Bruce banner was kind of this, you know,
Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde character,
Stan Lee thought it was really interesting to create a villain that was
basically just a man. There was nothing really special about him.
He didn't have any kind of super powers or anything like that.
It was just kind of like mankind against like it's, it's almost warring nature,
right? It's kind of what, what the incredible hope represented.
And so when Thunderball Ross was initially introduced to us, uh,
and the incredible hope number 291, we're given this story,
the Thunderbolt Ross actually comes from a family of people who were involved in
the military. And it was very much a source of pride for,
for Thunderbolt Ross to basically join up with what was the army air Corps at
the time in the 1940s, eventually that became the air force,
but the army air Corps at the time,
and then basically like Rose through the ranks exceedingly fast. Now,
one of the things that Stan Lee didn't really give us a lot of is whether or not
it was based largely on his abilities or on his family history, right?
Because I have to believe like most things in the world,
the military kind of allows you to move up in the ranks based on your own family
history, right? So the stronger your family ties with the military, uh,
and the more involved they were, the easier I think it is for you to move up.
I don't really have any evidence to support that. I'm not a military man myself,
but it's something that I always kind of believed to be true just based on my
own, my own work experience.
But regardless during world war two general Thunderbolt Ross actually moved up
to the role of the captain and fought in the Pacific theater.
But one of the big things that came out of Thunderbolt Ross came with regards to
a concept called control and control was given to us as this post-World war II
era.
I would say kind of think tank slash group now control was basically a handful
of gods, right?
So basically military officials that worked on the side of a really worked
alongside Boulevard,
Trask and looked at the idea of basically trying to stop future crises before
they took place. Now,
the notion of control itself was actually taken by the federal government and
rolled into what will become project wide awake with the rise of the meat and
population. Right? Of course, that was headed largely by Henry Peter Garak,
but for the most part control didn't last,
super long ended up being disbanded more or less. And of course,
the guy who created it, uh,
general Edward Harrison was kind of thrown away kind of blackballed as a crazy
guy. But the big takeaway from,
from Thunderbolt Ross came with the fact that he was stationed at the Los Alamos
research facility in New Mexico. Of course,
most of you guys are familiar with this as the place where Bruce banner became
the incredible hope for the very first time.
And the idea behind this was that Thunderbolt Ross had been consistently
presented to us as very much in being a kind of prideful man, right.
In the sense that his assignment here at the, at the,
the nuclear research facility kind of him off, right? He was,
it took place before the events of the Korean war and kind of ran through the
Korean war and after the Korean war.
And because of the fact that he had made such made such a name for himself in
the sense that those under his command had actually given him the nickname
Thunderbolt, because he just kind of flew in like a strike of lightning, right?
His ability to fly jets done and things like that, ah,
that it seemed like his entire entirely decorated military career.
It kind of fizzled out with him just working a desk job at some research
facility somewhere. Now, of course, he also spent time with dry and banner,
but one of the big things that came out of this is that his wife,
Karen had only given him one daughter, Betty Ross,
and it died when Betty was in her teens.
The other thing behind this is that because Betty Ross had basically been
brought over to, uh, to Thunderbolt Ross in order to, you know,
have a parent to raise her, he actually ended up shuffling her off to a, uh,
to a boarding school. And then once you became an adult,
she ended up coming back.
Now this sort of wraps around and bookends into the incredible Hulk. Number one,
when you have her encountering Bruce banner for the first time alongside
Thunderbolt Ross and Ross is distaste for Bruce banner initially started out as
something innocuous,
something small because of the fact that Bruce banner was the one who was
running the nuclear project. And it kind of off, uh,
off Thunderbolt Ross because in his mind it was a military project.
Therefore a military officials should be running it.
And because of his decorated history, he felt like it should've been him. Right?
So they, you know,
a lot of that pride kind of coming into foray and the fact that you ended up
having, uh, Bruce banner basically pushing, you know,
Rick Jones out of the way when the, the,
the initial gamble bomb was supposed to go off and then being exposed to those
and becoming the incredible Hulk. As we know,
it basically laid the groundwork for Thunderbolt Ross to go directly after, uh,
after Bruce banner, trying to figure out what in the world was going on. Now,
the other thing that we had going on here was a man by the name of Glenn Talbot,
who at the time, when he was stationed at desert base was basically a security.
Chief and a major, uh, but of course he would go on to become.
The husband of Betty Ross and, you know, at a future point in time,
but as far as Bruce banner himself,
and the relationship between him and general Thunderbolt Ross,
the other part of Ross's frustration with winning the show is that banner didn't
really live up to how Ross saw him.
That's all a man should be that he wasn't really masculine in the way that Ross
believed a man should be this.
And the fact that Betty was actually becoming attracted to a two Bruce banner,
which kind of him off because he always felt like, uh,
like Betty should basically marry a military man effectively led Ross to this
place whereby Bruce banner was essentially everything he stood against. Right?
And, and in a lot of ways,
banner was just kind of this guy who received this unfair treatment at a man who
is really just unhappy with this life, uh, Thunderbolt Ross,
looking back at his career and seeing how it all kind of seemed to coalesce with
what was basically a desk job and seemed to kind of take away from all of his
great military achievements along with, you know,
Betty Ross becoming attracted to banner banner,
not quite being the man that general Thunderbolt Ross thought he should be, uh,
what basically led to banner becoming just this target,
really just this overall vitriol and the fact that general Thunderball Ross just
didn't really like his life. Right?
And so when Bruce banner became the incredible Hulk, initially,
nobody really knew that he was the whole, except for Rick Jones, right.
He was the only person that ever really found out there did come a point in the
old, uh,
the old incredible hoax stories where it was believed that the hope was killed.
And this led to Rick Jones, basically telling a Thunderbolt Ross and, and, uh,
and Glenn Talbot and Betty Ross,
who the incredible hole actually was that it was banner.
And this is what off Ross,
because banner had seemingly gone from this man who was every ounce, you know,
kind of a weakling effectively, you know,
kind of a coward and the eyes of Ross to a man that basically toppled him right
there. And it just,
it was like this thorn in his mind that he couldn't quite get out.
And so the result was that he became the singular focus of Ross's interest,
right? Ross tracked him down almost every conceivable way. And these, this,
this kind of relationship, right?
The idea of the incredible health wanted to be left alone general Thunderbolt
Ross constantly tracking him down was a mainstay throughout all of the early
incredible hook stories, right?
This goes all the way back to the incredible hope. Number one 24,
it goes into the incredible hope one 45, the incredible Hulk number one 58.
And you have these different things that took place whereby you kind of saw
these moments where the halt might get some bit of a reprieve in the sense that
Ross had kind of taken pleasure in the fact that Betty Ross had actually ended
up marrying Glenn Talbot. It was always kind of this undertone, right,
in the sense that Betty was constantly being lied to by her father and saying,
well,
I want to do is cure the incredible whole realities that he wanted to kill,
right? He wanted to kill him, get rid of him,
or at the very least Panim over and,
and just kind of like break his body down and have him turned into a super
soldier, but there was never really anything. [inaudible] about the desire of,
of general Thunderbolt Ross to find the incredible hall.
Now this point specifically with the incredible hook issue, number 159,
Steve Englehart taken over the title, right? And we talked about the, the,
you know, some of the importance of his run, uh, in our video,
on the incredible Hulk explaining, at least I think we did a reworked video.
I don't remember if we did an update,
a video from your room original one that we did,
that was like nine minutes long back when I first started channel. Ah,
but what you ended up getting here in this, the Steven,
your heart run that ran between one 59 and a one 71,
as you had general Thunderbolt Ross who made a deal with the abomination
domination, at least the idea of it was that it would basically back down, uh,
the incredible Hulk and it would capture the incredible hope,
but ultimately of course we know the abomination failed.
And so this led to Thunderbolt ROS forming a team of Hoke busters inside Canada.
Of course it was done, you know, with,
with permission of Canada's department H but without happened,
this team was basically led, uh, by a man by the name of Colonel Jack,
Amber stir. Now,
Colonel Jack and Brewster was basically captured alongside the president of the
United States and general fundable Ross, uh, by the Soviets, of course,
this story kind of taking place during the cold war is one of the reasons why
you saw that kind of story happening because of the fact that the cold war was
very much a significant thing.
And Marvel back during that point in time running up until about the eighties or
so, uh,
really kept some pretty strong ties to real-world events as they were happening
at the time. That was one of the issues of the cold war.
Is it really permeated every facet of, of American and Soviet,
even worldwide culture, everything from, you know,
mutually assured destruction stories,
all the way up to just how like Soviets are a threat, right? Communism, all,
you know, all that kind of stuff. Uh,
the fact that that general Thunderbolt Ross had been captured by the Russians
was a massive source of embarrassment. And while he was eventually freed,
this led to a tablet being Calvin, uh, captured by the Russians,
which of course led Betty Ross to believe that general tablet had died.
And then it kind of her off and pushed her further away from her father. Now,
instead of identifying this as a direct result of what, uh,
general Thunderbolt Ross had done, and the fact that his obsession with causing,
uh,
capturing the Hulk had led him to this place instead of like mini stories before
it, he basically pointed the finger at the incredible Hulk and said,
if he didn't exist, none of this would be a problem.
And so this was the kind of storytelling that you saw that basically pushed
general Thunderbolt Ross further and further in his pursuit of capturing the
Hawk. Now,
the reality of this is Inglehart had actually left the title before this
particular plot thread was wrapped up.
And so with issue number 179 Lyn wine came over the title where he would
basically write until issue one issue 220,
and what's probably considered one of the most celebrated,
incredible home runs of all time. Yeah,
here is that Lynn wine kind of wrapped up these threads in order to sort of make
the title his own. And then just kind of took off with it by and large,
the idea of fundable Ross for the most part didn't really change.
And this wasn't really anything do you with the fact that it was a dislike of
Thunderbolt Ross Verlin wine, but more because wine,
one of the kind of introduced nuke concepts, right?
And so that's why you saw like Wolverine being bought in when you saw the
incredible health making his way to Canada, different things like that. Uh,
but for thought about Ross himself,
one of the big things that came out of it is that he was basically reduced to
having a nervous break down that after being basically removed from the project
green skin, as it was called, uh, and, and the entirety of the Hulk Buster base,
that Ross ended up suffering like a total nervous breakdown. Now,
originally he came under the care of doc Samson,
and that served the purpose of basically saying, Hey, you know, look, he's,
he's kind of being sort of that. Uh, but for the most part between this, the,
the, you know, capture at the hands of the Soviets, all these things,
they kind of led to the fact that he didn't quite feel like the soldier that he
wants was all led to him,
fully pushing headlong into the idea that the incredible hole basically needed
to be captured by the incredible hole needed to would just be captured,
but to be killed. Now, again,
a lot of the major plot threads focusing on Ross really came with the incredible
Hulk issue. Number 262 is when a lot of this stuff started. Now,
this really goes into what is considered to be the single most celebrated run a
really two runs of the incredible hope,
the first one being done by bill Matlow and the second one being by Peter David.
Now we've talked about the significance of these stories in the sense that
unlike Lynn wine or Steve Inglehart, or even Stanley and Jack Herby,
this kind of notion of the incredible Hulk embodying stories with flights of
fantasy and things like that were really removed.
And instead it was focusing largely on the human element of the incredible whole
introducing things like multiple personality disorder.
The idea that the incredible Hulk is a physical manifestation of the abuse that
Bruce banner suffered at the hands of his father, Brian banner.
Those were all major plot threads that came with the incredible hope line of
comics as it was written by bill Matt Lowe and built on by Peter David.
But as for general Thunderbolt Ross himself,
things actually really cool for his character.
And so starting in the three parts story to hunt the whole, the family,
the dyes together, and sunset of a samurai bill,
Matt Lowe introduced pottery one of the most significant events to happen in the
incredible hope mythos with the death of general Talbot.
And the idea behind this is that with Journal's habit himself,
following the nervous breakdown offendable Ross general tablet was the one who
was put in charge of gamma base.
And the idea was that general Talbot would effectively use his resources to hunt
down the incredible Hulk and almost pick up the Slack offendable Ross.
And a lot of this was based on the fact that Betty Roston basically already
established.
She was still in love with Bruce banner and it actually divorced general Talbot.
And so in the aftermath of this general Talbot actually committed treason and
then was ultimately killed in battle with the incredible whole consult.
And so going into, uh, the incredible hook issue, number 262,
and following the death of Talbot,
that this kind of further the idea of the intention of,
of Thunderbolt Ross to track down the whole end to take him out. And so well,
Thunderbolt Ross couldn't really be given the resources, uh,
to basically hunt down the whole property.
And a lot of this was due to the fact that Congress was devoting resources to
other things,
things as well as general Thunderbolt Ross has many failed attempts.
What the president ended up doing was putting general Thunderbolt Ross in charge
of a think tank that would basically allow general thought about Ross to track
down the hole. The problem with this is that an issue is two 78 and two 79.
This entire plan by the president that was basically formed by Thunderbolt.
Ross was essentially destroyed when you ended up having it established,
the incredible Hulk could maintain his own personalities, his own intelligence,
so on and so forth.
And the fact that banner was basically able to maintain his own identity when he
transformed into the halt.
This led to the president of the United States basically pardoning the
incredible hole of all of his past offenses.
And so what you ended up having was general Thunderbolt Ross,
who was in charge of something called project earth ball,
which basically led to him intentionally committing treason by freeing the
abomination who had already been, uh,
been held in status by the federal government and then working alongside AME
managed to pull it off. The problem is that,
of course the abomination was basically defeated by the incredible hall.
And then when the whole forced a general Thunderball Ross to admit his actions
in front of his daughter,
that this pushed Betty even further away and closer into the arms of banner.
And so what this did was leave Thunderbolt Ross in a state of complete and total
disgrace regarding his historical military career.
And he basically just kind of ended up becoming a wanderer.
But for the most part,
this became one of the most important aspects of Thunderbolt Ross's character,
because much like we had seen with the storytelling of bill Matlock refocused on
the human side of the Hulk, he did the exact same thing with Thunderbolt Ross.
And it was kind of an answer to the question,
what happens when all of his misdeeds and all the terrible things that he'd done
all in an effort to capture the hope basically came to fruition.
And so when that, when, when it all kind of hit the fan,
he was left as almost kind of a shell of his former self, right? He had,
he had already lost his wife at a future at a previous point in time.
Now he's lost his daughter, he's effectively lost his career,
but he seemingly had lost everything. One of the big issues though,
is that despite this work, that bill Matlow had put into the incredible Hulk,
ah, by the mid 1980s,
Jim shooter had worked out a deal with Mattel in order to create toys for Marvel
comics.
The problem is that Mattel wanted an event in order to market these toys.
And so Marvel ended up creating Marvel superheroes.
The problem is that the work that the,
that had been done on the incredible Hulk and even general Thunderbolt Ross and
coders like that, uh, it was kind of wiped away to some degree by Alan Milgrom.
And depending on who you talk to, some people love the work. He did,
others hated it,
but the idea of general Thunderbolt Ross is that he had this sort of redemption
story and a sense that between the incredible Hulk issue,
number 320 running all the way up to issue number 330 in this 10,
11 part series that you ended up having Thunderball Ross,
who basically showed up at the wedding of a, of Bruce banner and Betty Ross,
and that the intention was to basically stop the wedding from happening.
What you ended up getting was the introduction of this kind of living
electricity, Cynthia,
and energy called Zach's that had the intention of like trying to destroy well,
you know, do we,
what villains do the idea was that Thunderbolt Ross had actually stepped in and
basically sacrificed his life to lead the defeat of Zach's.
Now in this sacrifice, this,
this kind of redemption story that Thunderball rasa basically admitted,
he was wrong about everything with regards to Bruce banner,
that he really was a great guy, that he had to basically trust his daughter,
that his daughter knew a great man when she saw it.
And that in this last moment, he basically died in the arms of his daughter,
right. He died in the arms of, of Betty Ross. And so for the most part,
this saw the vanishing of, of general Thunderbolt Ross for quite some time,
in fact, for about 30 issues or so for 36 issues, we didn't really see him.
He did come back and, uh, the incredible hook issue, number 366.
But then for the most part,
we didn't really see him after that until we got to the incredible Hulk number
456, at least not really anything of note,
he was just part of the military and was just part of, you know,
basically there. And that was essentially it. Now, one of the reasons,
or at least I w I would kind of have to assume the reason for this was because
by that point, we were in the Peter David run starting in the 1990s.
And Peter David took a lot of emphasis off of villains that have been around for
a long, long time,
if they didn't really seem to serve a useful purpose of the stories that you
wanted to tell for the most part,
then general Thunderball Ross didn't really seem to fill that role. I mean,
he just did some things, but a lot of stories were based on like the leader or,
or, or like abomination or other characters that we were aware of,
or even just kind of building up on the incredible Hulk mythos itself,
kind of involving a lot of other characters that were going around.
The other part of this is that we were getting into the 1990s.
We were talking about the comic bus. And so for the most part,
there wasn't really a lot of room to tell stories involving characters,
villains, or otherwise, that really didn't draw a lot of fanfare.
And because comics in the 1990s were just super high octane and super fast
paced.
There wasn't really a whole lot of room to focus on somebody like Thunderbolt
Ross, who didn't really have any powers.
And his only real ally was the U S military that he could use to track down the
hook, not when you were standing in the face of like the abomination or you were
standing in the face of the leader or any of these other super powered beings
out there that could be used to create just super high intense stories.
And so what we ended up getting was basically going into the mid two thousands
with the launch of the incredible Hulk volume two,
and this basically saw the return of Thunderbolt Ross,
but not really the way that we intended. So with Greg Pak,
taking over the incredible hope line of comics in what's arguably the single
most popular run of the incredible Hulk in the history of the entire character.
Uh, we ended up seeing a series of events take place, right planet,
whole world war, Hawk, different things like that.
But the idea was to actually kind of introduce a secondary concept that was
basically new something that we hadn't really seen before. And it,
it really kind of happened as a result of two ideas coalescing at the same time.
So in an interview with the Washington post with writer,
Jeph Loeb Jeph Loeb had stated the idea for red hole kind of indirectly came
from him and ed McGuinness.
The fact that ed McGuinness wanted to draw the incredible Hulk and that they had
kind of had this idea where like the watcher would show up or something like
that. And the incredible Hulk would just get off and punch him.
And the reason for that was to establish the incredible Hulk truly was the
strongest character. There was right.
That there would be some story arc that would take place where the incredible
Hulk would basically fight against all the superheroes on earth and come out on
top. Right. And basically just kind of show to the reader. Yes.
The incredible Hulk is still the strongest guy there around that same time.
Joe Casada had actually either come up with the idea himself or use the idea
that was pitched in the 1970s with regards to the incredible hook TV show,
to have a red version of the whole, it was basically uninhibited, right?
It was just kind of a mindless monster, uh, that wasn't really,
it didn't really have to deal with the struggles of like Bruce banner,
keeping him in check or anything along those lines.
And so these two ideas effectively came together with the Hulk number one.
And this was something that kind of came in the aftermath of the world war Hawk
event,
that where Bruce banner had basically been locked away inside of a prison, uh,
three miles below the original facility,
where he was exposed to gamma radiation, that a new hope book was launched.
There was basically one of mystery. Now,
the funny thing about this is that people had looked at this number going
through forums and checking this out.
People had looked at this and they'd seen what the,
that it was Jeff lobe writing it.
And a lot of people seem to be somewhat disillusioned at the outset because they
were coming out of Jeff lobes, Wolf rain run,
which depending on which fan you talked to was not super well-received.
But the overall Jess is that for quite some time,
we never got an answer to who the red hope was. Instead,
the red hope just showed up on the scene and then was just attacking various
heroes. He was going even various characters,
but he was going after Windigo right. Just,
just characters that were traditionally, you know, villains of the, uh, of,
of the incredible hope.
One of the more significant things that red hope did was actually murder the
abomination. And it was really kind of Jeff lobe and an ed McGuinness,
his way of saying, look like this guy is not to be trifled with, right?
Like the abomination,
just given the incredible holder run for his money multiple times over the
years. Now, the red hope just killed it.
This and the fact that the red Holt was shown to be somebody of military
strategy, somebody with some great history looking in hindsight,
the clues were always dead, right. But for the most part,
we were all kind of wrapped up in the,
and not really able to figure out the fact that it was actually fundable Ross,
that, and the fact that Thunderbolt,
Rawson and missing and comics from up to that point about a 156 issues really
kind of made him sort of out of sight out of mind where you end up getting here
are some events where like, uh, the,
the red Hawk is basically brought together alongside, uh,
alongside a bunch of other heroes and a group called the offenders,
which is designed to be the antithesis to the defenders. Uh,
he ended up stealing like the,
the cosmic power of the silver surfer took the silver surfer,
surfboard killed a whole bunch of people. They were pretty,
they were pretty wild, right? Pretty nuts and, and pretty wild.
But while that was going on,
the next clue that we got in relation to the nature of the character was red
hook that's. It was really kind of building and brewing and,
and going into multiple things until we ended up getting into the world war
Hawks event, whereby we learn that the red Hawk is actually Thunderbolt Ross,
who had been returned that working alongside the intelligence yet,
which is kind of a criminal think tank organization.
That's headed by MODOK the general Thunderball Ross had actually worked
alongside Bruce banner.
And that Bruce banner was instrumental in the death of Thunderbolt loss. Now,
the whole idea behind this was to basically throw fans off the scent, right?
That we're fans we're slowly starting to pick up on the idea that general
Thunderball Ross was actually the red Hawk. This was designed to say, no,
he's not either, right.
To kind of basically eliminate people who could have been the red Hawk.
That's why that's one of the reasons why you saw characters like abomination
killed was one part to establish the power, the red Hawk,
but to also say red Hawks, not some new version of the abomination.
So this kind of, this,
this sort of pattern happened consistently across the board. But of course,
we also ended up learning things like the general Thunderbolt,
Ross who died was a life model, decoy.
The revelation that red Hawk is actually general Thunderbolt Ross.
And that's when things came so drastically with Jeff lobe,
leaving the hook series and an intern, Jeff Parker taking over as writer.
We actually saw the red Hawk because of his popularity being rolled over into
more stories. And in fact,
he actually ends up siding alongside captain America and then eventually joined
the Avengers. You get to the heroic cave story in 2010,
where you basically end up seeing the hood,
trying to capture the infinity stones and basically a new version of the
infinity watch, albeit earth-based is formed by captain America.
And the red Hawk actually gets the power stone, right?
So you saw these small little things taking place.
One of the bigger things to come out of this because of the red Hawk's ability
to siphon off the energy of other people was one of his main stays.
Marvel shook things up a bit by toying with the idea that it had actually been
taken away, but where it was initially restored,
this kind of revelation came out of it in saying that the ability of the wet
Holt to siphon the energy of others was actually quote unquote killing general
Thunderbolt ROS.
And so the result of this is that he couldn't transform back into a Thunderbolt
Ross form anymore.
And it was basically a way from all that to kind of get rid of the old hat
general Thunderbolt Ross stories to basically tell fans,
we're not going back to the age of comics where like the incredible hooks on the
run and Thunderbolt Ross is trying to track them down.
That red hook is basically here to stay.
And it made sense because it was just proved to be so popular at that point in
time, people loved him and they didn't want him to go anywhere.
And so by the time he got into 2012, you ended up getting a, kind of a,
a kind of team called the thunderbolts,
which differentiated from the original version that we saw that was led by Baron
helmet. Zemo this one kind of operated of its own accord and included general
Thunderbolt Ross as the red hole.
The problem with this is that by the time you got into the lead up to the events
of secret Wars, right?
Like most of the characters that we saw at that point in time,
Marvel was basically phasing things out and Marvel was kind of mobile had this
sort of giant checklist right in the background, not literally,
but more metaphorically, which characters stay in which characters go.
And while the red Hawk proved to be pretty popular,
I kind of have to believe that because the new incredible whole film was a
mainstay in the MCU. Even if people weren't super received to it, you know,
whatever Norton going into the incredible Hulk's involvement in the Avengers,
movies themselves, the, the main MCU story, uh, played by Mark refloat.
The idea was that there really didn't seem to be much emphasis on the red whole
consult. And so by the time you got into civil war II, 2016,
you got into the captain America run by Tanahashi coats.
Red Hawk was basically a background character, right? He'd been incarcerated,
and that was essentially it. You ended up,
ended up actually seeing his character killed off in the tunnel. HASI coats,
incredible hope run. And as far as I'm aware,
he hasn't really been seen since there was a bit of a revamping of the character
with new Avengers after secret Wars that was led by Robert Acosta. Ah,
that story kind of sucked.
And that version of the red Hawk wasn't very good at all.
But for the most part general Thunderbolt Ross as the red hope has basically
been gone this entire time. Now, if I'm a betting, man,
they're going to bring him back.
And the return of red Hawk is going to coincide with the introduction of the red
Hawk in the MCU.
That's usually why you see characters like that taken off the table is because
they're going to be brought back at some future point in time,
what that time happens to be. I don't really know what he's going to look like.
We have no earthly clue, but at the end of the day, that's just kind of the,
the bit of a rundown history. Now,
if you want more in depth stuff with regards to, to the incredible,
Hokulea more in-depth than we went here with regards to the red hook.
If you want more in-depth story there,
you can actually find the whole incredible hope run by Greg pack,
which includes everything we covered involving the red Hawk down in the
description, right? It's just this massive, great, big,
huge series of videos that we made. I want to say it's like nine hours long,
right? It's it's nuts. I think it's the longest full story video that we have.
It's crazy how huge it is, but it covers all the red Hawk stuff.
But for unexplained video that we usually try to keep under half an hour. Uh,
we did a pretty good job.
I think there's just a lot that happened with the red Hawk and a really long in
a really short period of time. But with that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain and make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the Rob port. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and I'll, we'll catch you all later.
Sure.